yosef candy for myself game you gotta
come back on the bike with you guys
today how's everybody today we're gonna
talk about the five secret weapons that
helped me learn to code better you guys
know I don't like wasting time let's get
to number five number five books we
understand the power of a great udemy
course the great lecture style that team
treehouse has some of the code samples
that free code camp has but there's
something about a book I don't know
about you but when I'm on a computer
like I'm doing a udemy course or
whatever I have like seven other tabs up
and I'm getting distracted all the time
and a book just minimizes those those
distractions the other thing about
ebooks is that the topics are indexed so
you can very easily flip back to
whatever you're trying to learn about if
you really want to double down on the
secret weapon of books pair them with a
video course because you get the audio
of the video you get the visual of the
video and you also get the visual of a
book and it really reinforces that
information number four a mentor I was
lucky enough early in this YouTube thing
to have someone actually reach out to me
this guy's a super talented developer he
checked out and he has been so helpful
with me coming to him with for real-time
information and real-time help when I'm
stuck on a problem and mentors mentors
are great when you're learning to code
because you can come to them and they
make you feel comfortable it's not like
Stack Overflow where there's this peanut
gallery just waiting to rip you apart
for asking a newbie question and I still
have him as a mentor I have my job but
I'm still asking questions about work
stuff when my senior developer is busy
or just on the weekends when I run into
something but rillettes have candy where
the heck am I going to find a mentor I
don't do YouTube chat I don't have a
freaking youtube channel that is a
perfect question to segue into secret
weapon number three tech communities the
IRL the best IRL groups to get into in
my experience our meetups you go to
meetup.com search for your technical
interest whether it's JavaScript UX UI
you name it it's out there there in most
major cities
even around the world these meet up to
take place and if you live in a rural
area or a smaller town make a point to
go to that city once a month or whenever
you can every couple weeks and just make
those connections and don't be shy about
introducing yourself because there are
people of all talents there's a lot of
people out there who really want to help
newbies because they remember how
frustrating it was and a lot of people
just like the challenge you know it gets
them out of their comfort zone online
communities are super diverse and can be
very helpful as well free code camp has
a great community the real tough candy
Gator chatroom there's newbies there are
seniors or people who've been doing it
for five ten twenty years plus and these
online communities are great places to
find that support get the questions
answered that you need answered and
progress in your learning in your career
number two in achievement journal this
is a low five method to track your
progress and really just flip the pages
or go through your digital notes and see
how far you've come you know you're
delving into so many technologies and
coming to a lot of dead ends getting a
lot of success points in there too but
after a while a lot of it just kind of
like melds together once you start
writing things down you can start
organizing your thoughts and that
organization that decluttering of your
mind really makes learning and retention
of information a lot easier I keep a
journal at work I have something you
know there's like to-do lists I have a
two did list so I have a physical
journal with a two did list and
sometimes I'll keep notes on my personal
machine as well and you can just use
something as simple as you know a little
note program where you date it and then
you just give bullet points on what you
accomplished that day after a while
after a few months of doing this you're
gonna see some big-time progression and
that can be a huge confidence booster
and a lot of times confidence is what
you need to learn more and keep pressing
on to practice these technologies and
feel confident in applying for jobs and
getting to that next level and finally
being number one method for learning how
to code go for a walk go for a bike ride
you like gardening get out and garden go
get some physical activity where you're
not focused on a
ughter encoding one of the quickest ways
to burn out and just get sick of it and
just stop learning is by staying on a
computer for 18 hours a day our bodies
weren't built for it and our brains
weren't either I mean the more you try
to stuff into your brain the less you're
gonna remember it doesn't have to be
this hardcore thing where three our bike
ride followed by an Ironman like it can
just be 15 minutes but it really is
important to just take a little break
from the computer from coding and let
that information process and again going
back to writing in a journal getting
your thoughts organized I've had a lot
of revelations about coding problems
just taking a walk going for a bike ride
being out in the woods thanks for
watching guys I'm gonna go run over some
more pine cones go get a fizzy water
maybe go get a couple chair or something
[Music]
[Music]